I read the book when I was probably 12
and I just loved it and I read every
book in this series I read a wrinkle in
time in sixth grade I thought meg is
like a quirky teenage girl that I didn't
really understand but I wanted to know
more about you can't keep using your
father's disappearance as an excuse to
act out this young girl on the journey
to find her father and herself what a
story
the great thing about a rink one time is
it has been translated into many
languages embraced by many different
cultures we were really trying to create
a film that has that timeless quality
this great adventure of a film has been
one of the great adventures of my own
life we heard a cry out in the universe
there's a lot and we're here to help you
find him I love that it's centered
around a girl who was having to travel
through different dimensions looking for
her father and through these adventures
she becomes this incredibly powerful
warrior for good
we aren't search of warriors you're
kidding
do I look like I'm kidding a little I'm
not
I'm not this book has got a big fan base
so how do you do that justice I've
learned a lot unfrozen about how to
challenge yourself to push the story to
higher levels you're trying to defy
people's imaginations but you're also
trying to ground it as something real
you're going to be tested every step of
the way this is a beautiful visually
dynamic adventure
Avis did very true to the spirit of the
book while updating it in a really
exciting way
we really want to serve the bands who
love these characters and so excited
about people seeing our bill
I trust you
you
you